breaking news coming out of Pakistan a
passenger plane has crashed in a
residential area near Karachi without
coming in to land at the city's
international airport well there was
almost a hundred people on board at the
time let's get the very latest now come
on hi Bert joins us from Islamabad come
on
first of all any word on those
passengers well it would appear that
they may be bad news as far as the
passengers is concerned because this
aircraft came over a residential area
which is all concrete area and
apparently the area is called model
colony this is just about a kilometer
away from the airport
this a320 Airbus was flying from the
city of Lahore it was on its final
approach to Karachi Airport we are told
that it had radioed the Civil Aviation
Authority about some technical issue
however we cannot confirm that at the
moment was on his circuit sorry on his
second attempt to make an approach to
Karachi Airport but when short went down
short of that Airport and it is feared
that most of those people on board would
be dead however they all because this
has come out in a residential area black
smoke billowing out of those houses that
were hit so it is possible that the
rescue that you see on the screens as
possibly the people who were injured on
the ground no official confirmation or
details about exactly what happened
we'll have to wait for that report to
come in but as you mentioned there were
over 90 passengers on board and the
plane was flying from Karachi
sorry lower to Karachi Sammy Kamali
mentioned there that the plane had
radioed in with some technical
difficulty do we have any details about
that at least of you know when it
radioed in for technical problems was
that just before the crash or had this
been going on for a while in the air
what we're told but as I mentioned to
you we have to be careful because it
hasn't been confirmed by the Civil
Aviation Authority we were I spoke to a
pilot's friend of mine who told me that
there was a report that the plane had
reported some technical issues was on
his second attempt to come in for a
landing but too early at this moment to
come out with any final verdict except
that this aircraft has gone over a red
over residential area and that the pilot
did not have time to reach the airport
that the aircraft went down about a
kilometer short of the runway the the
plane was heading to Karachi was this on
where it was doing their way it was
coming from any more details about that
for people who might be looking for news
about loved ones
this aircraft was flying out of Lahore
which is in Punjab this would be about
an hour's flight because it takes about
two hours from Islamabad which is almost
twice the distance so it was say it had
taken off from Lahore and it should also
be remembered that after the Cobras 19
emergency all flights were suspended
only recently PIAA decided to start its
domestic operations except for the
chartered aircraft that were taking
foreign nationals back to their
countries so the resumption of the
domestic service and of course with the
rest of one day because these aircrafts
would then have to go through the
cleaning procedures the SOPs in order to
ensure that there was cleaning done
onboard those aircrafts and only flying
on alternative days the aircraft took
off from Lahore for the city of Karachi
and then went down just short of that
Airport in Karachi about a kilometre
short of the airport and crashed over
residential houses all right thanks so
much come on Hari no doubt we'll come
back to you later when the details
become a little bit clearer but for now
that was come on how to bring us the
latest details from the crash of a plane
in Pakistan